all right so now after enduring yet
another baseless smear from the corrupt
mob and the media Congressman Devin
Nunez he is taking action filing a
bombshell defamation lawsuit against CNN
after they published an alleged false
story about Nunez traveling to Vienna to
dig up dirt on quid pro quo joke now
today's filing is explosive and exposes
just how wrong CNN got this and just how
low they will sing to try and smear a
duly elected member of Congress and of
course the congenital liar Adam Schiff
is not only continuing to steer
Democrats off the impeachment clip but
he's apparently promoting the smear
effort as well alleging that call log
showed Devin Nunez was working with Rudy
Giuliani to dig up dirt on Trump's
opponents in Ukraine all right here to
get into all the details of all of this
is Congressman Devon Nunez all right
let's first start with the lawsuit you
ever traveled to Vienna congressman I've
been in Vienna but I wasn't there in
2018 when I said when they said that I
was there so that's their problem let's
talk about the specifics of what they
got wrong and here's the other question
they do any due diligence never ask you
or your office well look here's my rule
with CNN for last two and a half years
and and most of the mainstream media
everyone in the Capitol here they know
it until they retract their fake news
stories about you know me being under
investigation me doing midnight runs to
the White House I've told them until you
retract I'm not acknowledging any
question that you give to me in this
lifetime or the next lifetime so they
know that I don't respond to any
questions I don't even knowledge
questions right but when they said that
I was in Vienna I was actually in
Benghazi I was the first member of
Congress to be back in Benghazi since
after the attacks meeting with general
haft our then I went from there to Malta
to actually participate in a
repatriation ceremony because we found a
soldier that was in the in the
Mediterranean we had the remains of the
soldiers so that he could be loaded back
up on a plane and shipped back to the
United States I was not meeting with
Ukrainians in Vienna in December of 2018
it wouldn't have been hard to prove and
I think the bigger point here Sean is
that they shouldn't be listening to
somebody who's been in
I did okay it's really really bad on
their part it's it's reckless it's
clearly reckless and look it's been ten
days I was on I was on this story came
out ten days ago I was very clear I said
it was the monster ibly false I think
that's a clear definition that I was
that I was denying it
they didn't correct the record I went on
your show and said a week ago and said
that I was gonna be working all week to
get all the facts to present them in
federal court so look I'm ready to meet
with CNN tomorrow they can put all the
facts on the table I'll put all my facts
on the table and we need to go to a jury
trial and let a jury decide whether or
not what's been done here is appropriate
because it's clear to me CNN has had an
axe to grind I mean how many times have
you seen it Sean you've seen it your
viewers have seen it CNN chasing me
around in the Capitol CNN chasing me
around back in my district in California
always with smears always with lies
always with fake news it just happens at
this time they went way overboard and
I'm not going to take it anymore so the
report your lawsuit goes on to say
because they were claiming their report
claim that you met with the Ukrainian
prosecutor fired son of a B they did it
by quid pro quo joe victor Shokan in
vienna in 2018 to dig up dirt on hunter
and joe biden that is you didn't go
anywhere near that area and nor did you
ever meet with the ukrainian prosecutor
that was funny because a joe isn't that
it's it's even better than that I have
pictures of myself in Benghazi and in
Malta at the time frame I mean this is
absolute definition of fake news right
and look I've made no secret that I want
to get to the bottom of who Fuzion GPS
is sources who are the Democrat sources
in Ukraine we've been looking for those
sources for a very long time but I will
tell you wasn't in Vienna and didn't
meet with this guy Shokan now maybe I
need to because maybe they have
something I know I don't know but it
makes me question whether or not now I
need to reach out to show can deceive
see what he actually has what about the
reports tonight that are just breaking
that revealed multiple calls between you
this guy Parnas and Rudy Giuliani my
sources are telling me that
the four so-called calls were apparently
to just Giuliani and maybe on Parnas
phone and under a minute is that true
well it's even it's even better than
that first of all you have to remember
the House Intelligence Committee we are
the Oversight Committee we have
Americans and foreigners contact us
every single day with information we
take that information you know we see
them somewhere we listen we say hey let
you know can you get this to the
appropriate lawyer or staff member on
the committee the fact that I know Rudy
Giuliani have known Rudy Giuliani a long
time and during that time if you
remember that was right when Robert
Moeller completely bombed and flamed out
so I remember talking to Rudy Giuliani
and we were actually laughing about how
molar bombed out so you know I don't
know maybe they have the recordings of
my phone calls with Rudy Giuliani
they're welcome to play them because
everything I spoke with Rudy Giuliani
about is nothing that I wouldn't care if
the American people found out but the
fact that the Democrats are using this
once again what are they doing they're
lying they could have told CNN that I
wasn't in Vienna they had the records
they wanted that story to be printed did
you talk to this guy less pardonnez or
whatever his name is you know it's
possible but I haven't gone through all
my phone records I don't really recall
that name you know I remember they name
now because he's been indicted but why
would CNN rely on on somebody like this
you know what I'll go back and check all
my records but it seems very unlikely
that I would be taking calls from random
people you know like I said we have a
process standard operating procedure you
call my office or you call me or you see
me out on the street I will do my job
and do my duty I'll get take your
information I'll get it to the
appropriate staff person or the
appropriate agency if that in that
matter and I will tell you this that you
know anything that we have from
pharmacist and his lawyers whatever game
they're up to we're gonna work directly
with the Justice Department to make sure
that these guys aren't just trying to
obstruct justice to obstruct our
congressional investigation or to lie to
Congress I can guarantee you that I
don't know what these guys are up to but
the long arm of the law is going to
catch them congressman good luck on your
lawsuit I think you have a strong case
I've read it we appreciate you giving
your interview here tonight absolutely